it's so interesting when you talk about
um
knowing one opinion that a person holds
and from that one opinion being able to
accurately predict everything else that
they believe yeah that mono thinking
just proves that you're not a serious
thinker well I I just it's fairly
obvious if for instance you say yeah
what's the problem with a big bearded
guy winning the weight women's
weightlifting I go okay I know all of
your other opinions as well and to be
fair that probably works the other way
around as well to a great extent the
interesting thing with most people is
where they're um slightly out of sorts
with their own political side and some
well that's exactly the point
that you if it's been a long time since
you were surprised by the opinion of
your favorite thinker or writer or
commentator or whatever it is that's
probably a reliable signal that they're
not really thinking for themselves yeah
if you're just permanently oh yeah it's
like an old leather pair of shoes here
we go again the the covid things
happened and I can already predict such
and such's opinion on it you go every
single time all of the time every single
time you know the idiosyncrasies of this
person's very very particular worldview
well that's because it's not theirs yeah
of course it's everybody else's it's
outsourced thinking and that what's
really sad about that is that uh it
means that you're not really living your
life I mean you're living a pasti of a
prescribed set of opinions that's so sad
I mean it's so sad the wasted energies
and wasted lives of people who've just
downloaded a set of opinions and they
just they're just running them yeah well
that's not your life it's just someone
else's life you're just replaying what
was that quote you talk me about about
being shunted to the side of the road of
your own it's a Philip Lin quote from a
poem his yes a description of a couple
and he says that something is pushing
them to the side of their own lives it's
beautiful line terrifying line
horrifying line should make everyone
yeah judge themselves what's it mean to
you oh well it means that there's a life
that you hoped to live you life you saw
yourself living and and you you got
pushed to the side of it and ended up
not living that
life I think a large number of people
have that almost all unhappy people I've
met have that feeling to some extent and
then you've got a choice of poisons one
of which is to choose the poison of um
other people held me
back another is to face up to the fact
that you in some way a
coward or a victim of circumstance or
something else but I think a lot I mean
you know you know one thing that young
people you know can be encouraged to do
is to set out the sort of Life they
would like to live imagine the sort of
Life they would like to live and then
aim for it and um working it out is
sometimes difficult sometimes not but if
you do have that image of your life that
you think it should be lived and you end
up not living it that that is particular
if you can feel yourself slowly being
pushed away from it I think that's a
terrible terrible feeling it's like
watching your own demise occur second by
second yeah fortunately I've never felt
it but I definitely fear it where do you
go to find or to avoid cowardice or to
find resilience or or bravery because a
lot of the time the easier path is
easier and it's the one that's got the
least resistance in surround yourself
with courageous people surround yourself
with um with brave
people and that can be bravery of all
sorts of different kinds and when I
turned 40 I had a a dinner uh which I
think you weren't invited to but it's
only because you weren't in town if I
remember rightly but I did get a lot of
my favorite people in the room at least
and it was interesting
that uh a friend made a speech in which
he said it's striking I won't say the
names of the people around the table but
some of whom will be familiar to
listeners but a friend of gave a rather
very touching speech I was very moved by
which he said how noticeable it was that
Douglas has surrounded himself with
courageous people and it was from a very
wide ARR array of bits of the world and
different disciplines and so on and I
was really touched by that because I
hadn't particularly noticed that I'd
done it um but then I realized I sort of
had that actually yes I had must have
subconsciously but maybe now consciously
wanted to be around courageous people
because I think that courage is
something that rubs off on other people
I think it's enormously to be desired to
to be around courageous people and there
might be different types of Courage some
of it physical some of it
mental um so that that's one thing you
surround yourself with courageous people
or at least not uh cowards not kettin
not the sort of people who just say the
same things that everyone's meant to say
and so on there there's many ways people
can get out of this non-life that they
are being shunted into one of my friends
it wasn't a friend at the time I just
met met him for the first time but
someone that I've been interested in for
a good while uh I met in Austin a while
ago
and he'd had a interesting story and he'
faced the cancellation over the last few
years and he sort of told me the story
and he said uh who sat on some
rooftop late at night talking about this
thing and he was regaling me with the
story he said throughout my entire life
I thought I was a hard man I like to do
man things and surround myself with
masculine people and I was into you know
like guns and shooting and fitness and
and friends with Navy Seals and all the
rest of it he said my entire life I was
scared that I was a
coward terrified that I was a coward and
he said uh in my darker moments I could
always hear my better self clearing his
throat in the room next door
beautiful and then this cancellation
thing came along and he said you know
even even the people that do really hard
things hard intellectual work hard
training work hard physical work all the
rest of it there's a difference in the
kind of difficulty that they do because
it's elected right you've chosen to do
the hard workout but when the entire
world comes to bear on you in a way that
feels like chaos and catastrophe whipped
up into a whirlwind and he said uh yeah
I that was a genuine test and he was he
was very grateful he said my my my
better self stopped his coughing and
kicked the door in and came to help good
uh which but just yeah I could always
hear my better self clearing his throat
in the room next door well the thing
with that is uh um the difference
between um uh situations you find
yourself in that are dangerous through
choice and ones that you've uh didn't
thrust into yeah been thrust into and
probably know that that that the
consequence of being thrust into danger
situation is much more likely to lead to
um PTSD and things like that um than if
you choose
to um and uh I've been fortunate in my
life the most of dangerous situations
I've been in have been ones I've chosen
to be in um and that's that's very
different
um but yes I'm well I'm glad he found
out that he was more courageous than he
feared but think about that what a
beautiful line you know to be to be more
courageous than you feared were right
you know this this almost this war
against
yourself yes that's right this fear of
your own nature well that but that it's
perfectly sense I mean there a there a
horrible example I sometimes use but I
mean
um if you're ever mugged for your wallet
let alone you're mugged with somebody
else let alone if you're mugged with a
girl that you were with or looking after
and you just handed it over there like
there's there's several reasons that
it's worth handing over the wallet for
one of which is like why do I need to
risk getting shot for like stabed or
stabbed for 100 100 bucks and a few
phone calls to the bank yeah so that's
like the
reason to hand over the wallet what I
care uh the reason not to hand over the
wallet uh is are you sure that you're
not going to spend the succeeding weeks
Dreaming Dreams of pornographic violence
against your
attacker and thinking thinking of how
you're going you would torture him if
you could get your hands on him and the
brutal way in which you would have
Revenge if you ever find him it might be
easier to just get your head kicked in a
bit yes and are you sure you can live
with a version of yourself that is you
handing over the wallet I said this
recently in a piece of New York post
about the people on the New York subway
where there's this awful thing you've
probably seen where people you know like
a woman will be being abused by some
Maniac fentanyl adult you know um drug
addict and and you know people will like
either look into their phones including
men or they will get their phones up and
like
record and I mean somebody said Douglas
is trying to get people killed and I
wasn't obviously but what I was saying
was where are the men just like stand up
and like confront the guy if he's got a
Woman by her hair and is parading her
around the
carriage and yeah the the backlash was
like what do you know these people might
get killed if they step in but M say
yeah but also maybe will have a more
Civil Society if people don't think they
can go around and do this stuff without
consequence
um I'd like to see far more standing up
like that I think it's a pathetic
position for particularly for men to be
in to sit there like getting out their
mobile
phones but you know it's everyone's
choice I don't exactly know what I would
do in some of the situations I've seen
you know read about on the New York
subway in other news this episode is
brought to you by Maui newi
venison Maui Nei venison brings the
healthiest red meat on the planet direct
to your door not only is it the most
nutrient-dense meat on the planet
they're the only 100% stress-free wild
harvested venison that you can get
here's my super secret hack if you are
sick of buying meat that always goes off
put it in the freezer from Frozen salt
both sides of it put it in an air fryer
for 10 to 12 minutes each side and you
have a perfectly cooked steak from
Frozen that will never go off because
it's going from freezer to mouth in the
space of 25 minutes it's a complete
GameChanger all of the cuts are
spectacular and you can get them Frozen
delivered to your door but their venison
sticks are my favorite while I've been
on the road you can get the healthiest
red meat on the planet delivered
directly to your door and get 20% off by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to Maui venison
docomond wisdom and using the code
modern wisdom check out that's M AI nuu
venison docomo wisdom and modern wisdom
at checkout thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Douglas you will love the 2hour long
podcast episode which you can watch
right
here go
on